you see fauci yesterday and I don't
think it was a slip of the tongue
because I think I definitely heard on
NPR but I thought I also saw it on on
MSNBC where he said hey now that we're
getting it this we get up to 90 or
whatever we can have our hands around
this our arms around this uh a plague uh
by the fall of 2022 and of course the
politicians blew up the Democrats blew
up and he walked it back on Anderson
Cooper last night my point there's been
so much information put out there that
has just been inaccurate to the point
about the other Jabs which which got uh
Dave Rubin taken down off of Twitter
would have gotten us canceled off of
YouTube that turns out to be the correct
thing 60 days later there's so much in a
complicated topic so much is is being
important given to the American people
that turns out to be just not accurate
right and they're naturally inclined to
say hey prove it to me let me pull up
the story we have from timcast.com oh
two years to slow the spread fauci hopes
to have coveted under control by Spring
of 2022 in an interview with CNN's
Anderson Cooper
fauci came out and said he misspoke when
he said fall and he really meant spring
and you know what
if it was a mistake okay
that's fine sorry I I I get it fauci
yeah you made a mistake here's the
problem do you buy that it doesn't
matter if I do okay it doesn't matter
first of all I
trust and distrust of CNN and fauci
here's the real issue fauci could be the
nicest guy in the world fauci could be
you know he comes over for dinner and he
brings a casserole with him and you're
like oh you didn't have to do that fauci
thanks so much but he's been wrong too
much it's not about whether I like him
or think of him as a bad person or
prescribe male intent it's that he has
flip-flopped on so much and so here's
the big problem there's no anchor I mean
literally like an anchor in the ground
for people to understand their reality
yes so when the news comes out on
Thursday and says by fall of 2022 and
then the news comes out on Friday by
Spring of 2022 and then you go and talk
to him Mom Dad brother sister relative
and they're saying we all got to do this
otherwise we're gonna be locked down
until fall of 2022 and you say no CNN
said it was spring of 2022. what are you
talking about and then you're both
showing each other articles from within
10 hours of each other contradicting
each other because fauci doesn't know
what he's talking about
I see this a lot on Facebook someone
will post a story and it'll say some
fact or guidance and I'm like that story
is from a day ago it's already been
contradicted but they don't want to hear
it because they're like look I read the
news this is a new story it's from 12
hours ago saying this thing is true and
then I'm like yes but he came out again
and said this and they're like I don't
know what you're talking about so now
you have people clashing into each other
arguing over what is or isn't and
getting banned for it the funny thing
about Dave Rubin getting suspended on
Twitter for saying that booster shots
were coming was that he was actual he
when he got finally released from
Twitter jail he's like here are the
articles I was reading and they said our
booster shots on the way booster shots
may be coming soon and now where are we
at the FDA says and I want to make sure
I pull this up because YouTube is a is a
Fickle Beast they say the vaccine also
continues to be available under
emergency use authorization including
for individuals 12 through 15 years of
age and for the administration of a
third dose in certain immunocompromised
individuals
you know what they didn't say
a third dose for all individuals
so when they're talking about booster
shots for everybody that's not in the
fda's letter for even emergency use
authorization they only are referencing
certain immuno compromised individuals
now when the New York Times comes out
and says FDA is recommending a booster
shot after eight months but the FDA
comes out and doesn't say that yep what
am I supposed to base my my
understanding off of yep I well I want
to just clarify this these boosters
moderna Pfizer go so on so forth and
booster shots all for the alpha variant
for the original covid variant Alpha and
beta Alpha Beta which are no longer the
problem what we're looking at right now
is a mutated version assuming it's going
to mutate again and again and again and
again so these vaccines are not for the
Delta variant which is the current
mutated strand right so a lot of the
stories have just said the vaccine you
know retains a certain amount of
efficacy for the Delta variant that's a
weak way of saying it's not the right
vaccine it's it's it's
yes okay right so I'm trying to use my
words carefully because for the Nuance
they're saying it works
it wasn't designed specifically
targeting this this that's so important
and for them not to be hype to be
shining Spotlight on that is is like so
this is okay so the the the uh right
after I was here uh what four five six
weeks ago the Surgeon General of the
United States came out with this big
report and said and attached to this
report said the Surgeon General went to
the White House number one Health public
health issue we have right now right not
even covet it's misinformation remember
that it's misinformation that that's now
a Public Health crisis misinformation
and they listed you know Bobby Kennedy
and Dr Mercola and other people all
because internet
I think one of the reasons that fauci
has so imploded in in uh in in people
and not just Integrity but people with
authority people really listen to him is
that shows like this like war room and
others get so much into the details of
these things people just don't want to
watch General political TV anymore I
don't think they're really thirsting for
answers and for experts and for data
information to make up their own mind
not to be told
but um it like in the like in the movies
show don't tell right they want to see
access information so when fauci goes on
CNN and msmc it speaks into kind of
these General big picture phraseology
and then it changes and the goal posts
change first you got here at immunity of
70 from people who've had it next thing
you know oh herd immunity is 90 you got
to be vaccinated right
people get naturally because I think
we're in a time and you see this in the
Apes people are crowdsourcing knowledge
all the time right now they're going to
say oh you have to be a trusted you have
to be a trusted source for that
information just to clarify the Apes as
a reference to the stocks to the stock
to the the GameStop the ape Nations like
four million individuals and they're
teaching themselves how to trade stocks
or they're having people come in and
they crowdsource they're becoming
experts they're not experts they're
becoming proficient in understanding
finance and economics and the trading of
stocks as they teach themselves I think
you're seeing across the board in many
many different areas look at the people
just two examples and this is populism
look at what people know about vaccines
and pandemics today that 18 months ago
would never know look at look at
critical race Theory I know so many
mothers who were let's say this not
exactly a students and we're partying in
college people I know my age maybe some
relatives maybe a sister of mine that
are experts in Herbert Marcus no but
they they know critical race Theory like
Andrew Breitbart to it I mean they've
gone through and studied they've gone to
the source material we had a woman on
last night from North Carolina they can
give you chapter and verse they never
heard of critical race Theory Derek Bell
you know six months ago right but for
crowdsourcing and getting knowledge to
going up a learning curve you're seeing
this in in every different area around
and I think people they want if you've
got to be managed by experts the experts
I think have to come out and really lay
out things in a very definitive way
that's a good point I mean we're seeing
more and more people start to do
research they never would have done in
the past the way I uh this is
interesting I'll we'll talk a little bit
about Bill Maher in a second but I was
thinking I was thinking about Bill
Maher's show because of the news about
him rejecting booster shots and I'm like
you know the problem with Bill Morris he
doesn't actually read into the news he
just watches the TV and then bases his
opinions off of what he sees on TV and
you know what that probably worked when
Bill Maher was younger and that's how he
got to where he is today the news used
to be only a handful of channels
so when he's coming up into prominence
there's a handful of channels you can
watch where you could get distilled
information he does his political
commentary based on this the information
he was presenting was probably wrong or
misleading but we didn't have crowd
research now 2021 Bill Maher comes on
this on his show he gets the Covington
kids wrong right he gets a lot of these
things wrong and he doesn't understand
but you can see that he's clearly on the
side of Liberty or or more so on the
side of that I think he's kind of red
pilled you think he's red pill yeah let
me tell you but there's yeah real quick
just yeah you're right
but he he's like one percent you know
he's missing so much context and
information first so his show I think is
one of the best produced shows I've had
a chance to be on there a couple times
and twice up front his Show's one of the
best producers the staff does an amazing
job of the detail remember he is a
stand-up comedian they and very
quick-witted so I I find his stuff
actually be pretty piercing as far as
getting to the point
let me tell you a story about the
pandemic so they call me up to to come
out uh to um in fact in February January
right when the pandemic started to come
out and talk about the primaries on Bill
Maher on Bill Maher yeah in the front
the front of the show when you come out
this thing like the second time I've
done it I've done the panel years ago
about Sarah Palin but I said I'm only
going to do it
if we talk about the pandemic I've
shifted my podcast from impeachment to
pandemic this is the end of the world
it's going to be it's going to it's
going to change the world as we know it
you have to understand it and they go
fine I fly out there and staff's
terrific they come to me and they say
look
um here's the deal uh Bill loves you
it's going to be a great session up
front but he wants to talk about the
primaries he wants to talk about Bernie
you can't mention the pandemic I go whoa
and the producer say hey all we do is
follow it and we're watching your show
because it was the early stages I said
no no I said this is going to change the
arc it's going to change the it's going
to change the uh the election right and
uh and they said uh no we can't do that
what he'll do in the introduction he'll
introduce you as the host of the new
podcast War Room pandemic but then he
wants to talk about politics although
the staff and these guys and he just
made a decision and it was quite frankly
to your point it was a miss his staff
was very much saying hey we want to do
the pandemic he made a decision hey this
pandemic thing sounds like the flu from
China let's do I want to talk about
Hillary and I want to talk about
Bloomberg I want to talk about those
things are current however I think and I
think this is why particularly in the
Trump movement the populist nationalism
I think Bill Maher is someone
every week on woke culture you're seeing
what I call Old lions like that who come
from a more of a liberty although
they're Progressive they come from a
Libertarian base right a Libertarian
perspective that are at the Vanguard of
of countering and throwing off awokeness
I appreciate him um I think it's good
there's a lot of people you know he had
Ben Shapiro on recently you see the Ben
Shapiro Malcolm dance thing yeah yeah
and and wow when I watch that you really
understand how you're out I mean Ben
shapir versus Malcolm Nance that's not a
fair that's outmatched not just that but
like I didn't even his Senior Chief
Petty Officer Nance is a good man I
don't agree with this this part but he's
outmatched by Ben Shapiro even with
Nance not there I was really impressed
with Ben Shapiro he's fast he's
knowledgeable it and it was and and he
look
Bill Maher is outclassed by Benjamin big
time yeah you know so I'm watching that
I'm like wow you know like this is why
people this is why Ben is like one of
the biggest podcasters and one of the
biggest Personalities in this and uh but
you know what you end up seeing with
this is that Bill Maher
he should have known a lot more than he
did and so to to like you know what
happens in these debates with the you
have Malcolm Nance you have Ben Shapiro
and again Ben shapiroquest both of them
in my opinion Bill Maher
here's one of these like left
Progressive people say something and
I'll say oh I understand that okay and
I'll agree with that and it's like Bill
if you actually read the story you'd
know that they were wrong you know so I
get accused of being right wing simply
because I actually fact check things and
a good example um well I don't want to
get too much into the but when you see
the the news come out I think we'll call
you right wing for more than that but
that's okay no I mean that's the that's
the main like that's that's it oh
because when you factor I think come
back and say you're a right winger yeah
when you have a fact so if I say
something like versus an emotion also
something like Afghanistan is you know
the general idea I said is a lot of
people want to pass the blame for what's
happening in Afghanistan the the
Democrats want to blame Trump the Trump
supporters will blame Biden ultimately I
think full responsibility to a great
degree is George W bush for starting the
war in the first place Obama for
escalating and keeping us there but I
think it is factual the nation building
not the war yes nation building I think
it is factually inaccurate to say that
it is Trump's fault for what's happening
in Afghanistan because it's not his plan
it's ridiculous he negotiated a peace
deal it's not being followed through and
Trump has no leadership over the current
situation so it is factually inaccurate
to say that trust but what happens then
is they say aha Tim's defending Trump
and I'm like in the sense that he's not
the president right now he has no
control over what's going on but then
they'll call me conservative because a
fact will happen I'll give you an
example I I know everybody who's
listening they're going to be like here
he goes the economy again do you think
the economy is good or bad
right now I think they kind of I think
the economy for Working Class People was
terrible inflation's out of control
you're getting crushed every day it's
awful independent voters and Republicans
would agree with you but Democrats
overwhelmingly think the economy is good
right now because they bought into it
hard they're not giving me the truth he
saw the polling today on USA Today 30
forget the Democrats so overweight to
Biden right now because they're still
they're still hanging on because he's an
orange man bad it's orange man bad
32 percent only 32 of independent
support by Biden's presidency is over
the regime is over it's now time to
cauterize this and to make sure it can't
do any more damage permanent damage
permanent damage to the American people
and to our Republic and that's what's
happening right now with the financial
what they're doing the passing these
bills they just had to vote today the
six trillion dollars they want to add
this regime is over and here's why look
at look at this poll from USA Today
Suffolk which is a center left or
left-wing polling group it's not a war
room and it's not uh it's not the
timpole show right it is 32 percent of
independent support approval Biden Biden
went from a plus 20 on the Davis
inauguration a plus 20 approval to a net
negative 14. there's never been a drop
this quickly in uh in uh in the
presidency ever by anybody this is an
implosion and there's no bottom to this
guy there's no floor this guy could get
to the high 20s he just announced look
he sent a CIA director over to
Afghanistan to be lectured by the
Taliban and look I'm a big guy about it
and the CIA the head of CA the header CA
is going to fly over to have a meeting
to be told you guys are leaving and
getting out of here and now tonight he
just announced we're starting to
withdraw because it takes a while to get
the apparatus out the apparatus is
starting to be moved out and right now I
think Daily Mail reported there's
hundreds of Americans have been
evacuated just hundreds and there's 15
000 estimated from what we know we don't
know nobody's given us a firm and I
understand you might not have it down to
the fifth decimal place but can we know
if it's 5 10 or 15 000 are they in Kabul
are they throughout the country and
what's going on look American
citizenships have some value you
shouldn't just be left behind like trash
right and this is why this is the
presidency that's imploding right now
and nobody can sit there and look at
these inflation numbers Working Class
People the inflation's out it's not
transitory it's because the way we're
financing this it's out of control the
wealthier you're going to get wealthier
your audience particularly under 35 I
told you before you're going to be
Russian serfs now now you're going to be
impoverished Russian serfs okay it's
just this is just the math thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time